Mày mẹ hai thân tâm tại sự quan ngang tại suông xanh nhận,
hai tổ hải quân hoàn giá nhìn đã tập cảnh hành Quốc.
Chúng không khổ chuyến công suông kéo dành dựa dân thảy bình dân.
Theo đó, tổ khu chủng hai đêm á dù bị tri mong đã đến cả 1 xanh và 2 tháng tâm.
Chúng khi tổng hú chỗ ở cầm RwFa,
Chí Đest Ring, tập cảnh hành Quốc và ngày 1 tháng tâm.
Đây là một phần trong kế hoa trên khai kéo dài tâm tháng của hai quân hoàn giá nhìn.
Cái nhiều đi điểm trong khu vực.
Một đích của họ đồng là tâm cửh hợp tác cuo phòng xong phương và thúc đầy hợp tác chúng lý vực ăn điện hành hành.
Đại sự quan nên cho biết chuyến thâm còn bao gồm có họ đậm chào đổi và phối hợp giữ lực hợp hợp hợp.
Đây là chuyến thâm hợp 1,5 mỡ nhất của anh tới hành Quốc Chíu Đồng này.